[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tour sur le plateau de ballons ce temps
poste on a débattu et comment du voile à
la vaccination obligatoire ou pas des
soignants mais là nous allons changer
toute assez de sujets puisque nous avons
le plaisir de recevoir olivia ciapa
soyez la bienvenue on peut l'applaudir
vous êtes réalisatrice romancière
photographe d'art et vous êtes c'est
surtout le autre débat de ce soir vous
êtes une femme transgenre et pour la
clarté du débat on va quand même
préciser déjà deux mots auparavant on
entendait plutôt parler de transsexuels
et là je vous ai présenté comme sam 30
jan quelle est la différence entre les
deux termes et est ce que vous vous
acceptez le mot femme transgenre alors
oui j'accepte tout à fait ce terme là
pour vous expliquer la différence entre
les deux ça fait à peu près un petit peu
plus d'une dizaine d'années qu'on
utilise plus du tout le terme
transsexuels puisque ça insinué que
c'était un changement fait qu'il y avait
un rapport avec la sexualité or c'est un
changement de genre social en fait donc
c'est pour ça qu'on dit transgenres
puisque ça n'a pas de rapport avec ni le
sexe ni la sexualité d'accord et le
deuxième mot qui va peut-être intervenir
dans notre débat c'est un mot anglais
des dom alors littéralement ça veut dire
le nom morts qu'est ce qu'on entend pour
les transgenres par non morts dont qui
est bonne alors ce qu'on entend par ce
mot là ce sont des dés c'est le prénom
que la personne avait avant qui était
donnée par ses parents d'accord donc du
coup moi monde et nîmes c'était olivier
mais normalement je devrais enfin il
s'avère que je
l'avais déjà donné avant mais les
personnes trans en général n'aiment pas
du tout donner lors des 2èmes donc il
faut vraiment pas leur demander
je suis un peu une exception parce que
j'avais la chance d'avoir une popularité
un petit peu avant et mai mais c'est
vrai que souvent à partir du moment où
elle change de nom elle aime pas du tout
du tout qu'on revienne sur l'ancien
d'accord alors vous êtes né holliger la
dernière fois vous promets que j'utilise
votre dès demain votre nom mort vous
êtes devenu olivia est ce que vous avez
su très tôt qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui n'allait pas que vous viviez une
identité qui n'était pas celle que vous
visiez de l'intérieur celle que vous
vous assignez n'était pas la même que
celle que vous visiez à l'intérieur
alors moi c'était
très très tôt effectivement peut-être
vers 3 4 ans où je les
formuler de manière très simple en fait
à mes parents et je voulais vraiment
être exactement comme une petite fille
et ils ont eu un rejet extrêmement
violents par rapport à ça j'ai vu là une
manière très simple ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que pour eux j'ai pour moi
j'ai leur montrer que j'étais une petite
fille vraiment et là quelle forme vous
vouliez vous habillé en fille par
exemple exactement exactement et donc du
coup ils montrent plus que rejetée ils
vont vraiment renier à ce moment là et
donc j'ai fait ensuite tout l'effet
inverse c'est à dire que pendant des
années je me suis organisé j'ai fait
tous les espèces de clichés de ce qu'on
appelle la masculinité toxiques donc
barbu musclé tabac je faisais de la boxe
du ju jitsu j'étais voilà donc quand tu
es vraiment dans ses clichés là et parce
que je voulais avoir l'approbation de
mes parents être aimé par les parents et
indirectement à avoir l'approbation de
la société et être aimé par la société
même comment comment vous viviez
psychologiquement cette dissonance parce
qu'il y avait une forme de de trahison
envers vous-même en fait n'était pas
fidèle à vous même pas ce que vous
ressentiez comme le vous même oui mais
je n'ai pas ressenti comme ça parce que
le fait de vouloir absolument être aimé
par eux et par les autres c'était plus
important pour moi je pense que d'être
moi même mais je pense que j'étais là je
n'avais pas le courage de me dire je
m'en fous je veux juste être moi même
quelle que soit la la conséquence que
les gens m'aiment ou pas ça m'est
complètement égal j'ai juste envie
d'être moi même j'avais pendant l'ag
comment maintenant j'ai 42 ans j'ai
commencé à 41 on va revenir là dessus on
n'est pas du tout la capacité de pouvoir
de pouvoir prendre ses décisions et
avoir ce courage en fait mais est-ce que
vous manifestiez cette dissonance
uniquement vers vos parents ou vous
ouvriez de la chose auprès de proches
d'amis le camarade d'école je pense que
c'est compliqué tout le monde en fait
j'étais en gt en performance tout le
temps j'étais en performance d'extra
virilité
et je suis rentré dans une espèce de 2,2
moulin peut aider
et
de cette espèce de mecs sexy un peu le
fantasme des ghetto savait qui était qui
était insupportable ce que j'étais tout
le temps tout le temps j'étais en
performance que ce soit dans ma vie
privée que ce soit même dans ma vie
amoureuse dans ma vie sexuelle j'étais
en performance totale et s'était
complètement une prison alors qu'est ce
qui a motivé le fait que vous passiez de
cette étape d'ultra masculinité comme
tout laisse penser à une volonté de
transformation c'est à dire de mettre en
adéquation votre genre est ce que on
vous le ressentirez j'ai eu un déclic en
fait l'année dernière il ya un an à peu
près
début juillet de l'année dernière en
fait j'ai fait d'autres raisons
différentes en fait j'ai fait une
tentative de suicide et je suis restée
cinq mois dans le coma nantes a toujours
lié à cenon nié avoir grand chose
d'accord mais je suis resté en fait 5
jours dans le dans le dans le coma et
est en fait quand je me suis réveillé je
n'aurais jamais dû me réveiller
normalement et je me suis dit arrête à
partir de maintenant j'ai droit à une
seconde chance j'ai droit pouvoir
renaître comme je remets en vie et en
fait appartement j'en ai plus rien à
[ __ ] c'est à dire que je pourrais
perdre tous mes amis je m'en fous je
pourrais
perdre tous mes employeurs je m'en fous
pour avoir tout le monde qui me
ridiculise sur les réseaux sociaux ça
m'est égal et plus que ça j'avais la
chance en tant que comme de plaire
plutôt pas mal et d'avoir l'impression
pouvoir coucher avec à la fois tous les
hommes gays y que je voulais et toutes
les femmes hétéros et je me suis dit à
partir de maintenant peut être que plus
personne ne voudra
coucher avec moi ne voudra avoir envie
de ça m'est égal en fait et je j'ai
envie de faire ça pour moi et je me
lance et je m'en fous de tout voilà
c'était alors ça c'est de la décision
maintenant il a fallu la mettre en
pratique et telle est facile quelle est
la première étape la première étape en
fait ça a été de voir un il faut voir
d'abord un psychiatre qui valide en fait
que vous êtes bien une personne trans et
qui fait une lettre pour que
l'endocrinologue vous délivre en fait
des hormones féminines c'est à dire des
estrogènes c'est-à-dire
ddd de la progestérone et des bloqueurs
de testostérone et en fait je regarde un
peu en arrière que quand je passe
l'entretien c'est quel genre de
questions vous pose pour établir que
vous êtes une personne trans à
cdc des entretiens qui sait
voir un psy pendant plusieurs semaines
c'est long c'est très long we qui va qui
va poser des questions sur sur tout un
tas de choses et c'est lui qui va dire
un jour c'est bon je suis d'accord et
moi je voulais tellement que ce soit
propre que j'ai vu deux ou trois ans il
ne semble pas de vraiment en parallèle
pour avoir deux lettres est vraiment
faire montrer que bien donc aussi un
traitement hormonal donc
l'endocrinologue qui donne le traitement
et après vous êtes lancé avec les
hormones votre votre votre corps ce
champ vous avez une répartition des
graisses qui devient féminine vous avez
une poitrine en fait qui pousse
vous avez vous avez tout un tas de
choses comme ça qui change et qui est
votre regard se transforme donc là je
suis en transformation je suis en
évolution ça va durer encore plusieurs
années mais comment s'appelle retient
elle s'appelle li lo et son denim
[Rires]
retrouvera bientôt dans un cabaret
l'ange adorait les coordonnées [ __ ]
mais c'est une expérience totalement
enfin vu de l'extérieur comme ça
totalement incroyable comment où vit une
transformation même si elle est
souhaitée comme si à votre cas comment
on vit une transformation aussi radicale
de son corps écoutez moi je
depuis un an je vis une espèce de d'
aventure complètement magique c'est une
envie à une constellation d'étoilés
autour qui que je trouve assez assez
incroyable et il ya ça ne s'arrête pas
en fait c'est à dire que j'étais à
chaque nouvelle à chaque nouvelle étape
chapeu quelque chose de nouveau qui se
passe ça ne descendent pas en fait je me
sens tellement bien tellement épanouie
enfin vous avez l'air en tout cas n'ont
même pas idée à quel point c'est c'est
une année magique mais incroyable et on
m'avait dit il y avait des femmes trans
qui m'avait dit tu verras quand tu vas
faire ton coming out public
tu vas perdre tous tes amis hétéros tous
tes amis gay toute ta famille tu pourras
traîner qu'avec des personnes trans donc
on a fait très peur je me dis je m'en
fous je m'en fous je suis allé à la
télévision je suis passé sur votre
chaîne d'ailleurs ou ou jeu bien cerné
par les voies
et et en fait ça a été tout le contraire
c'est à dire que j'ai conscience d'avoir
un privilège et que c'est très très rare
j'ai une très très grande communauté sur
les réseaux sociaux et il ya eu une
espèce de mouvement d'amour comme ça qui
m'a il ya des dizaines et des dizaines
de voir des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui m'ont suivie sur les
réseaux sociaux dans cette aventure on a
l'impression que c'est des personnes de
ma famille là j'étais en thaïlande pour
faire une vaginoplastie mais on va aller
reçu des dizaines de milliers de
messages le jour de l'opération de de
soutien fin j'avais l'impression que
tout le monde est avec moi si vous en
parlez relations que c'est une
renaissance n'est fait exactement
l'impression que j'ai mais vous n'avez
même pas idée à quel point ben justement
pour la vaginoplastie quand je suis allé
au global au parti alors rentré dans les
rentes ai rien peut-être plus à quel
saint se passer une vaginoplastie
d'abord la thaïlande pour unia thaïlande
alors pourquoi la thaïlande parce que
avec ça c'était juste avant de rentrer
c'était dix minutes avant d'aller
d'aller d'aller sur le roc opératoire et
la télévision du coup on m'avait suivi
jusqu'au bloc et c'était mais le plus
beau jour de ma vie sert qu'au fur et à
mesure j'arrive on me place dans un
fauteuil roulant à décembre mais c'était
incroyable avancer vers la lumière gmt
dans un une extase
incroyable pourquoi la thaïlande oui
parce que alors qu'en france c'est
complètement remboursé par la sécurité
sociale mais j'estime en tout cas pour
moi d'après toutes les recherches que
j'ai fait qu' ils ont dix vingt ans
d'avancé sur nous et qui peut faire des
choses absolument incroyable donc je
suis allé voir celui qui est pour moi le
meilleur chirurgien au monde et je les
fais je les fais là bas du cou alors
vous parliez tout à l'heure des choses
qu'on peut dire ou pas d'hier mais voilà
qu'en fauteuil roulant
en général en général on ne les
personnes trans en fait tu n'aimes pas
du tout parlé de changements en fait
deux sexes parce que comme c'est un
changement eux c'est un changement
social de gens qui se passe dans la tête
conseille vivement bruno peur avant une
opération a nommé
[Rires]
je le dis franchement mais la peur j'ai
pus tard dans la même journée vous avez
même pas idée je pense que c'est le plus
beau jour de ma vie branle de loin j'ai
tellement bien j'en avais rien à [ __ ]
que les caméras me suivent jusqu'au bloc
opératoire j'étais super bien bref
c'était c'était les personnes trans en
fait de monde souvent ils disent non je
fais un genre social pour la plupart des
personnes trans ne veulent pas faire de
changement de sexe et donc du coup ne me
posais pas cette question parce que j'ai
pas envie de vous dire ce que j'ai entre
les jambes ça ne regarde que moi et là
et la personne avec qui je vis il
s'avère que moi j'ai extrêmement
médiatisé donc je peux en parler pour ça
rhinoplastie donc en quelques mots ça
consiste en quoi ça consiste à retirer
en fait le pénis et à avoir un vagin en
fait avoir un vagin une bulle exactement
du coup comme une femme et grâce à ce
médecin qui peut faire des choses
incroyables
on peut avoir
c'est plus que le même âge en fait c'est
à dire qu'on peut avoir des orgasmes
vaginaux d orgasme clitoridien on peut
on peut on a un ph à l'intérieur du
vagin qui exactement le même qu'une
femme c'est exactement exactement pareil
l'odeur le goût tout est pareil voilà
c'est non on vous fait confiance à
bouffer bon sens
mais c'est une opération qui demande
après d'autres opérations un suivi très
longs ou c'est quelque chose qui se fait
assez rapidement le changement définitif
alors j'ai eu cinq semaines
d'hospitalisation là bas et j'ai eu
trois opérations en fait et ensuite dont
la dernière opération juste avant de
prendre l'avion cédé il ya quelques
jours et j'ai pris la roma je suis
rentré donc donc là c'est terminé en
fait d'accord alors il ya une différence
qu'il faut quand même souligner c'est
qu'évidemment il n'ya pas d'organe
reproducteurs la lame chirurgie ne va
pas jusque là ah non pas du tout non
se plaindre ça viendra non mais dans un
terrain inconnu comme ça on se pose des
questions qui vont vous paraître naïf
c'est peut-être le cas donc il ya ni ni
organes reproducteurs ni je n'ai pas mes
règles non plus d'accord non mais comme
ça c'est complet
c'est une petite question parce que
je le vois super épanouie super heureux
- c'est vrai que la plupart du temps des
gens dans dans son cas de figure
généralement c'est un petit peu la
galère vous avez eu aucune difficulté
parce que on a l'impression que c'est
disney à quoi de plus tout à glisser
alors et on a déjà entendu des
témoignages de personnes qui sont dans
la même dans la même optique que vous
qui galèrent dix fois plus comment ça se
fait que vous ça a l'air d'être si
magique et ben en fait j'ai envie de
dire c'est c'est parce que les médias
ont besoin de présenter tout le temps la
trans identité comme quelque chose de
tragique de difficile avec des
personnages des personnes en fait qu'ils
ont des problèmes mentaux souvent et
c'est peut-être une des raisons qui fait
que j'ai attendu 25 ans pour le faire
parce que dès que je voyais à la
télévision ou même au cinéma ou dans des
séries des personnes trans c'était
absolument tragique c'était terrible au
cinéma on avait chaque fois soit des
personnes trans qui était ce qu'on
appelle l'usurpatrice c'est à dire une
femme trans qui se fait passer pour une
femme pour une femme si ce genre dé ces
gens c'est à dire les femmes ou alors on
avait des serial killers comme dans
comme dans l'oeuf un le silence des
agneaux et c'était terrible c'était très
pesant et à chaque fois qu'on voyait des
reportages à la télévision c'était tout
le temps d'aider des personnes parcours
du combattant c'est ça c'est ça donne
quand les personnes rendement de même
chez mac ne dis pas que ça en fait moi -
les personnes trans que je fréquente en
fait elles ont un parcours pas hyper
magique c'est pas ça c'est pas le mot
c'est disneyland c'est pas loin c'était
à parfumer rue recommence tout est enfin
c'est incroyable quoi s'est il enfin je
peux pas parler de choses mauvaises
parce que je vis une expérience nouvelle
germanique souligné c'est vrai que il
parlait de galère parfois c'est plus
qu'une galère il ya des cas assez
tragique de gens qui s'y colle au gicm
ans louise assez mal ou alors ça se
passe pas aussi bien peut-être qu'en
tania lanka vers d'avoir une tradition
dans ce domaine alors c'est vrai
effectivement mais c'est pas que ça
c'est juste que les personnes comme moi
jusqu'à présent on ne les voyait pas la
télévision en fait vous voyez c'est
juste y en a la majorité quand même
c'est des gens qui galèrent quand même
qui ont des difficultés
ça dépend des personnes trans hormis or
mais côté famille avec vos parents ou
j'ai compris que ça a été difficile est
ce que le regard des autres qui vous
entourent mais même pas parce que je
vais vous parler voilà ma famille et moi
je m'étais dit de toute façon je le
ferai quand j'aurai 60 ans comme les
parents seront morts et ma soeur sera
morte parce que je ne voulais pas qu'ils
main valide qu'ils utilisent pour me
ridiculiser pour me rabaisser et en fait
et en fait savoir que le hasard fait que
j'avais coupé les ponts avec eux depuis
quelques temps depuis des années j'avais
coupé les ponts avec ma mère et elle m'a
vu à la télévision en parler et elle a
repris contact avec moi depuis avril et
aujourd'hui c'est ma première convient
sport en fait pas vraiment elle
m'appelle deux heures par jour quand
j'étais en thaïlande elle était là tout
le temps en facetime et c'est absolument
fabuleux donc je peux pas inventer une
histoire tragique alors que
le bémol cela dit c'est que du coup vous
l'avez entièrement financé vous même et
que ça c'est pour le coup pas donné à
tous et pas donner c'est pour ça que
quand tu entres eux sont bien ça vous a
coûté plus de 15000 euros et quand je
parle de privilèges c'est à dire que
j'ai le privilège d'avoir une une
communauté fabuleuse sur les réseaux
sociaux qui m'a aidé à pouvoir le faire
en fait j'ai
ggg en échange de dons de 100 euros j'ai
donné mes photos à ma personne de ma
communauté et en quelques jours on a
réussi à avoir une somme génial et ça
j'ai conscience que c'est un privilège
qui est très intense apprend en france
pour le faire en france lorsqu'on n'a
pas les moyens de partir en thaïlande
est-ce que c'est long aujourd'hui alors
tout dépend si vous voulez avoir les
meilleurs chirurgiens français cissé des
meilleurs chirurgiens ça peut prendre
plusieurs années puis cette année leur
année avec des résultats je prends je
devrais pas dire ça mais j'ai vu des
résultats vraiment catastrophique tout
ce que j'ai vu elle avait le le vagin
qui ressortait et j'avais le vagin
atrophiée elle avait le le vagin qui
était vraiment pas le fin c'est faudrait
pas normalisé nos trop encore à paris
génère ont peut-être une tension way une
souffrance dont peut-être fêté à jérôme
et qui c'est vrai que vous vous ne le
voit pas chez vous parce que vous avez
pu assouvir rapidement cette urgence
de chez vrai vous avez complètement
raison et c'est pour ça que je parlais
en fait de privilèges que j'ai c'est à
dire qu' il ya des personnes trans qui
sont qui sont qui vivent complètement
isolés et qui perdent leur travail
qu'ils ont effectivement beaucoup de la
loi française est assez difficile par
rapport à tout ça la chance des mesures
exigées d'avoir une communauté qui me
soutient c'est pas donné à tout le monde
donc j'en ai avaient choqué au papier
pardon aux dernières traites pratique
gta civile comment ça se fait un peu
féminin s'inquiètent des
possibles
oui c'est aussi fait qu'on est très long
il faut passer devant un juge jusqu'à il
ya deux ans en france il faut savoir que
pour changer de genre sur ses papiers il
fallait être castré les gens savent pas
donc c'était quand même violent comme
comme et il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qu'on pourrait faire pour
faciliter
parce que les gens n'ont pas la chance
et le privilège en fait que j'ai donc
c'est l'occasion de le dire car je
voulais bondissant bonsoir merci pour ce
témoignage extrêmement précieux et c'est
vrai que c'est bien de voir qu'à des
personnes qui font leur transition de
manière plus facile et voilà qu'ils
éprouvent beaucoup de bonheur mais je
pense que c'est important effectivement
comme vous l'avez fait de rappeler que
la situation des personnes trans en
france est assez difficile il ya une
association que je suis notamment sur
instagram qui s'appelle accès accepte
testé qui justement oeuvre pour
permettre aux personnes trans d'être
prises en charge sur le plan de la santé
parce que en réalité il ya quand même
pas mal de discrimination qui existent
notamment dans le monde médical parce
que le fait d'avoir un corps qui n'est
pas nécessairement en accord avec ce que
la société attribue à un genre ça peu
exposées à des discriminations et
parfois des questions un petit peu
intrusive tout à l'heure vous avez
évoqué dans votre parcours le fait que
vous ayez vous ayez du rencontrées par
exemple un psychiatre je sais que cas
moi j'ai lu beaucoup de témoignages de
personnes qui disaient que justement
c'était une intrusion qui faisait qu'en
fait un certain moment de leur vie y
avait une étape ou en fait de
l'extérieur on leur impose et de se
conformer à une certaine un certain
comportement une certaine identité pour
que leur transition et lors la manière
dont ces personnes sont identifiées soit
validée par le corps médical et séverac
c'est grâce aussi à des personnes qui
ont beaucoup milité pendant très très
longtemps que les changements ont été
possibles sur les papiers d'identité
aujourd'hui les personnes trans sont en
tout cas quand on a les statistiques
pour beaucoup en situation de précarité
elles sont aussi surreprésentés dans les
personnes qui sont par exemple
travailleuses du sexe et elles sont
exposées souvent à des violences il ya
des personnages besoin d'une avocate
voilà des personnes chien quand même à
voilà une personne que vanessa campos
qui a été victime justement je vois ça
marche parce que c'est important aussi
de rappeler que si aujourd'hui vous êtes
là olivia et je le dis enfin je pense
que vous êtes beaucoup plus concerné que
moi c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui sont mobilisés
pendant des décennies qui ont beaucoup
souffert et parfois qu'ils ont perdu la
vie pour vous permettre aujourd'hui
d'être parmi nous et j'en suis très
belle plaidoirie maître diallo
vous souhaitez
répondait alors tout ce que vous venez
de dire je suis entièrement d'accord et
d'ailleurs vous venez pas ce qu'on avait
vu de questions avant vous avez répondu
à tout ce que je voulais dire après
c'est j'aurais dit exactement la même
chose et vous avez complètement raison
il ya effectivement énormément de
personnes trans qui sont précarisées qui
sont travailleuses du sexe est pas
anodin ce qui s'est passé pour vanessa
compose dans une espèce de 2,2
les gens n'avaient absolument rien à
[ __ ] et c'est vrai il y a des gens qui
se mobilisent ya des personnes trans qui
se battaient des personnes trans qui
perdent leur vie est en fait je fais
partie de ces premières personnes trans
qui ont 7 7 ce privilège en fait ça me
fait penser aux personnes gay qu'on
commet aux orgues et qu'on commence à
voir à la télévision où tout a l'air
bien tout à l'air beau aujourd'hui en
oubliant les dizaines et des dizaines
d'années de personnes qui sont battus
pour leurs droits qui ont galéré comme
c'est pas possible effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être quelque
chose de nouveau de pouvoir faire une
transition heureuse une transition qui
épanouit et ses essais et c'est vraiment
pas donné à tout le monde il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui sont dans cette
souffrance et dans cette précarité quand
on parle de personnes trans migrantes
notamment de personnes trans gr 6 et où
ça monte encore plus dans les
difficultés
on est dans une société qui
effectivement très dur moi aujourd'hui
c'est que je rentre dans un magasin sans
ouvrir la bouche parce que j'ai la voix
un peu grave là encore parce que je suis
mais aussi bavard avant ou depuis
refaire un peu d'humour
oui il ya des ja il ya effectivement
énormément de 2,2 et j'ai perdu ce que
j'étais
dans un magasin même sans parler avec un
masque et tout on me dit bonjour
monsieur
c'est donc et les gens le voient ils le
savaient tout cas c'est pas toujours
effectivement c'est facile c'est moi qui
ai décidé à ce que en fait c'est moi qui
décide et à ce que ma transition soit
positive et soit belle et ça tout ça
mais la société fait quand même en sorte
que ce soit pas le cas moi je vous prie
de m'excuser je pense que je vais un peu
brisé l'unanimisme et d'enthousiasmé
autour de ce plateau mais mais en
[Rires]
vérité je suis je suis assez triste est
vrai un peu inquiète aussi pour la
société dans laquelle on vers les
petites batailles vous allez comprendre
vous allez comprendre pourquoi en
réalité moi ce que je trouve triste
c'est que votre histoire elle et elle
est relativement marquée par la
souffrance je vous l'avais pas dit tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs mais il ya
l'histoire évidemment avec avec vos
parents cette blessure d'enfance et puis
vous avez pas expliqué les raisons de
votre tentative de suicide mais moi je
me souviens parce que je vous le
suivaient avant c'est une histoire
glauque sordide vous avez été victime
d'un harcèlement atroces sur les réseaux
sociaux et je je je vais jamais vécu
dans ces proportions là mais je
comprends très bien qu'on veuille mettre
fin à sa vie parce que ce que je savais
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que il ya ces
souffrances et puis ces questionnements
que vous avez depuis manifestement très
longtemps et à un moment donné vous
apporter comme réponse cette position
moi ce qui me ce qui me comment dire ce
qui m'a m'interpelle depuis quelques
années a insisté dans laquelle on vit
c'est qu'en fait je constate et je pense
que c'est d'ailleurs réel que qui en
fait beaucoup de gens se posent ces
questions d'identité de gens etc on sait
un débat médiatique récent mais en
réalité je crois que ça a toujours
existé les gens qui s'interrogent sur
leur identité et aujourd'hui si vous
voulez je me demande si vous réalisez je
sais que c'est pas votre attention parce
que vous avez l'air très sincère mais si
vous réalisez qu'en fait vous participez
d'une forme soit les deux d'ambiance âge
médiatique et qui confinent parfois même
un peu à la propagande c'est à dire que
en gros vous avez on a pendant longtemps
montré la face compliqué de tout ça et
aujourd'hui vous venez nous présenter le
visage radieux moi je pense que c'est
ces questionnements en gros le fait de
croire que la consoude le sexe le genre
n'est pas innée mais est une
construction et qu'on peut le choisir je
pense que c'est une mauvaise réponse
apportée à des questionnements que
beaucoup de gens se posent et quand je
vois l'explosion du jean du nombre de
gens qui se déclarent aujourd'hui non
genre et par rapport à cet été il ya 30
40 50 ans on voulait passer une mode non
c'est même pas qu'une mode justement
on aggrave la finition froid et on ne
serait pas dans les plates-bandes c'est
ce que je crois qu'il se met en place
dans les médias notamment et c'est pas
une question de mode c'est vraiment une
question de réponse apportée à des
questionnements et parfois à des
souffrances que je trouve si vous voulez
complètement chimérique et il est
illusoire et moi c'est ce qui m'inquiète
c'est dans la société de demain si on
apporte cette réponse là tous les gens
il n'ya pas longtemps il ya eu un
témoignage à la télévision qui a
beaucoup heurté les gens c'était un
gamin de moins de 10 ans qui qui se
déclare et femmes esseulées je trouve
que
ben ils déclaraient pas femme il l'était
il a pas voulu changer de corps ait
voulu récupérer le corps qui lui étaient
dues et ben je crois que c'est faux en
fait voilà vous avez peur d'un
bouleversement civilisation tour mais
mais qui est bien le risque c'est le
risque c'est que des gens étaient des
gens comme yann par exemple disent
aujourd'hui il n'a pas voulu changer de
corps il a voulu récupérer le corps qui
est bon mais jamais remplacer sur sa vie
vient mais peut-être qu'à lui expérience
en valois on écrire mais je fais pas
peur je
vais juste vous avez un message et vous
dit aux garçons peut-être aux jeunes
ados à la maison mais attention faut pas
le faire vous lui mettez la pression
s'est passé attendez je vais je te
répondrais
branche d'olivier est vrai que c'est pas
vraiment génial chaque mois juste raquel
pardon que je finisse ses échanges avec
rakia au tribunal c'était on est amené
maintenant non ce que je voulais dire
juste raquel ce que l'on fait pas peur
mais il ya deux façons parce que tu as
déjà perdu tu sais déjà que tu as perdu
ce que je veux dire c'est que il ya deux
façons d'aborder la question moi
honnêtement je fais attention et je
constate que quand on dit c'est génial
c'est c'est une femme il veut juste
récupérer son corps je trouve ça trop
facile et je suis pas certain que ce
soit un bon modèle pour la société
olivier que ce soit quelque chose qui
apporte beaucoup de bonheur à ces gens
que c'est trop facile mais c'est moins
que jamais
je pense que les concernés par la
question
j'essaie de répondre parce qu'il ya
plusieurs choses là je fais pas dire
alors vous avez parlé effectivement de
du harcèlement dont je subis c'est vrai
que ça a été très très médiatisée à
l'époque c'est venu jusqu'aux menaces de
mort sur les lieux où j'allais de
travailler tous
c'est effectivement une chose qui est
pas banal quand ça vient de la part de
milly milliers de personnes de compte
voilà c'est une chose que font les
réseaux sociaux louis leca balle de 2
euros de militants lgbt si je me suis
alors quand même oui ça c'est trop long
pour en parler là
olivia sur oui ou non c'est lgbt oui ou
non c'était des personnes radical en
fait des personnes militante radicale la
lorraine jeu oui d'accord voilà il
s'avère que voilà par rapport à ce que
vous vous dites je n'ai pas trouvé une
solution
pour aller mieux par rapport à mon
suicide c'est très différent c'est à
dire qu'après mon suicide je n'en avais
plus rien à [ __ ] et donc je pouvais
faire ce que j'aurais dû faire beaucoup
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps et en
fait si j'avais vu quelqu'un comme moi à
la télévision comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure qui a l'air vraiment heureuse et
tout bien si je l'avais vu 25 ans plus
tôt j'aurais fait ma condition 25 ans
plus tôt mais tout ce que j'avais vu à
la télévision que terrifié et vous
disiez vous parler de propagande par
exemple il faut savoir que des enfants
entrant en fait comme moi je l'étais il
y en a toujours eu c'est pas du tout une
question de mode et où que ce soit une
réponse non binaire mais a toujours eu
il s'avère que ces enfants avant vous
aviez pas le temps de les voir grandir
puisqu'il se suicider en fait il était
suicidé beaucoup plus tôt beaucoup plus
jeune et on ne savait pas vraiment
pourquoi ou quoi que ce soit il se
suicider son enfance aux adolescents
soient doute parce que la société leur
renier leur renier leur leur propre
identité voulait les uns visibiliser
quoi mais alors maintenant il ya pas de
ses chances entre les deux vous n'êtes
pas de complètement sel parce que sa
part de sa part comme ça
s'est même essayé de laurent chez carré
mais il me reste très peu de temps s'il
vous plaît faites moi
je partage l'idée de geoffroy s'est
effectivement je pense que pas un
phénomène de mode parce que ma décision
non mais
allait se faire opérer ça c'est une
démarche très difficile qui s'est pas
sur un coup de tête il ya beaucoup
d'étapes donc je pense qu'il ya une
véritable demande ou à une veine bab
véritable souffrance qui à un moment
doit prendre fin justement dans ces
démarches ça je vous comprends moi j'ai
suivi quand je t'ai nutritionniste
beaucoup de gens qui parce que quand on
prend des hormones si vous voulez c'est
très difficile de prendre désormais de
transformer son corps et c'est notamment
sur le poids mais là où j'ai un petit
hésitation aussi et je suis gêné c'est
effectivement chez les enfants moi je
pense qu'un enfant avant qu'on puisse
vraiment dire qu'il est trans il faut
laisser un peu grandir alors je ne sais
pas quand je ne sais pas mais la
majorité est pour moi non mais pas la
majorité c'est pas une question d'âge
mais au moins moi quand j'ai vu cette
langue en tout petit sur un plateau télé
ça me dérange pas parce que je trouve
qu'en plus effectivement on n'a pas à
mettre sur un plateau télé un enfant
pour effectivement mettre le doute
mais tout de suite mais dans la cage de
france un enfant oui on a compris ce que
voulait dire en fait
coupé juste
le temps lui en fait c'est très simple
c'est à dire qu'en faites vous il faut
pas oublier une chose c'est que quand un
enfant né voulu imposer un genre social
par rapport à ses parties génitales
c'est à dire que vous dit toi tu seras
un petit garçon dans tout ce que ça va
aller dans le genre social feu tu seras
une petite fille par rapport aux gens
sociale il faut juste écouter les
enfants des fois si un enfant ne se sent
pas dans ce genre là il faut vraiment
écouté des enfants voulu imposer un
genre par le prénom par la coupe de
cheveux par les habits par la douleur
les impôts et de comment vas tu renonces
et b non non non la nature elle impose
juste des parties génitales et c'est
après que tout le reste va aimer un
enfant c'est la société qui l'imposent
et des fois il faut savoir écouter les
enfants si un enfant dit ça ne me
convient pas ça n'est pas moi c'est pas
des quotidiens sénégalais temps je suis
désolé vraiment sonné je suis désolé de
taxer les rentrées potager si on est
d'accord rien et monia karim est
vraiment très rapidement non mais moi si
je suis honnête si je suis totalement
honnête je vous dire que au demeurant je
suis culturellement assez éloigné de ces
phénomènes de transformation ne pas vous
raconter d'histoires je suis pas
familier avec ce genre de phénomène je
ne dis pas que je suis totalement à
l'aise mais à y réfléchir comme le dieu
auquel je crois et très tolérant et très
respectueux à l'égard d'autrui quand je
vous entends
je me dis
olivier s'est suicidé il ya une
renaissance
en olivia qui me paraît épanouie qui me
paraît heureuse qui me paraît trouver sa
place dans la société et ça même si je
suis culturellement éloignés je ne peux
que constater être rose et être repos
[Applaudissements]
je la trouve les délais se terminèrent
je vais être un peu désagréable je vais
être un peu désagréable avec mes amis
quand j'entends parler de phénomène de
transe de ce sont deux modes extérieur
en fait je mets un petit peu en colère
il ya quand même une raison objective
il ya quand même quelque chose de
biologique lorsque le sexe chronique
lorsque le sexe chromosomiques état ne
coïncide pas avec le sexe anatomique il
ya quand même une un dysfonctionnement à
la base qui est d'ordre biologique
technique ça c'est la première chose
lorsque vous avez quelqu'un qui
ne trouve pas sa place non pas dans la
société
non pas dans son entreprise mais dans
son propre corps qui sent bien que son
vrai corps est ailleurs elle attend
quelque part que ce n'est pas celui que
la naissance lui a imposée parce qu'il
ya un dysfonctionnement une distorsion
entre ces deux sexes bien sûr qu'on
parle pas de sexualité au sens de
sensualité n'en parle quand même d'un
organe génital et effectivement le la
société nous a imposé un genre qui a le
malheur de coïncider avec le sexe qu'on
a à la naissance et donc on est formaté
une bonne fois pour toute dans quelque
chose qui nous empêche qui nous empêche
peut-être pas de mourir mais qui nous
empêche de naître quinze secondes et les
battre
olivia vous l'avez dit vous avez une
grande communauté sur les réseaux iard
quand vous avez annoncé votre votre
venue sur notre plateau ya plein de gens
qui ont ri comprendre répondu en dessous
en disant fais attention ils sont sont
pas forcément bienveillants sur ce
plateau avait en tout cas sur votre
twitter lily des centaines de messages
d'une jeune fille s'est donc c'était
juste pour assurer tout rassurer votre
servante et pourtant on accueille nos
témoins allaient bien celle du rêve
bienveillant mais là où on accueille
notamment avec bienveillance peut y
avoir des incompréhensions mais on sait
recevoir un jamboree notez-bien prix de
chant des taxes est une question de vie
ou de mort bien comprendre qu'on soit
les deux meilleures de ma foi un
traitement médiatique très focalisés sur
le changement anatomiques sont les
maquillages et cetera et c'est vrai que
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les personnes trans des fois hésiter à
aller dans les télé parce qu'à côté
spectaculaire on l'a vu d'ailleurs qu'on
vous avait montré les photos de lisier
la publication et on peut penser qu'à la
maison les enfants des gens et c'est ça
qui est spectaculaire et donc il faut
faire attention à pas trop
spectacularité je trouve que ce soir on
l'a fait correctement en étant à
l'écouté je sais bien que chroniqueuse
en tout genre font gagner du temps ce
sont environ des gens qui naissent plus
tard que les autres vont très bien c'est
en tout cas je suis sûr mais la
confusion et pour olivia williams oui je
suis là pour vous d'accord avec vous et
dabo est ce que quelque chose avait
pensé du débat voilà donc vous cédez
vous étiez c'est
un débat contradictoire c'est normal oui
mais c'est mal qu'ailleurs
rien et qu'une violente et de débat à
avoir sur une l'identité de quelqu'un
genre je suis pour ou contre votre
identité c'est très violent je l' ai
déjà vécu par rapport à la halla halla
au débat qui avait au moment du mariage
pour tous où on avait très vite des
débats sur pour ou contre votre
existence ou pour compte l'existence de
vos familles ou en tout cas c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui si à la fois je vais sur
des plateaux télé qui sont populaires
comme vous dites et si j'ai cette
communauté sur les réseaux sociaux aussi
qui est aussi grande c'est que je
permets à des tas de jeunes olivia qui
ont peut-être quinze ans qu'ils ont
peut-être vingt ans de leur montrer ce
que moi j'aurais adoré voir donc je leur
fait vivre toute mon aventure au
quotidien depuis le début et on est à la
fois leur montre ce que j'aurais adoré
voir et à la fois j'essaye d'éduquer à
ma manière sur les réseaux sociaux les
personnes si ce genre comme vous c'est à
dire 1 et femme au nez hommes et qui
sont en accord avec leur genre de
naissance et de l'heure de leur montrer
ce que c'est parce que je me dis s'il
peut avoir de l'empathie pour moi s'ils
peuvent mais messi peuvent apprécier
les pour ont aimé apprécié toutes les
autres personnes trans qui n'ont pas le
privilège d'être là donc si vous voulez
me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux je
cherchais olivia s'il n'y a pas de géant
que le mot de transe disparaîtra